um Alex or Alexandra and I'm gonna talk
tonight about taking risks and an
experience that inspired me to do so
many years ago
so I'm gonna try not to cry but maybe
I'll cry and it'll be fine
four years ago my father who was 65
years old or something got diagnosed
with cancer so we're all together for
Thanksgiving
we got the news and four months later he
was gone so we're not gonna talk about
that's not story but something that at
the time I didn't think would really
like impact my life and like inspiring
me to like make a change ended up doing
so a few weeks after my dad passed away
my mom asked me if I could help her with
something so she set that before my dad
died he left a business transaction
pending so someone would owe him money
if the transaction went ahead and that
she would receive the money if you know
that was came to fruition and so she
wanted me to find this John Doe
and make sure that he stuck to his word
so I'm like okay well I don't know this
John Doe I think I met him once like a
few months ago when I was visiting my
dad while he was sick but I'll figure
out a way to get in touch with him so I
remembered that many years before my
siblings and I had helped my dad to
create his first ever email account so
we decided on hotmail.com
because it was very hot at the time and
we created a password that all of us
could remember because we were sure my
dad would want to access the account
from our computers and then he wouldn't
remember the password so we settled on
something easy and I was sure all these
years later maybe like 13 or 15 years
later that there was a very slim chance
that he had changed the password so I
opened my computer I put in hotmail.com
I hadn't been there in a very long time
put in the credentials acess first try I
was inside his email right it's kind of
creepy you know it's the email of a
deceased person you don't know where
you're gonna find but it's not a story
about that so I find this like 10
of emails of like Facebook asking him to
come back and find what his friends are
up to and Linkedin telling him about the
friends that got the new job and Dropbox
being like you have like a new file or
something I'm like this is weird so I
have to find John Doe right that's what
I'm in there for I search his name I
find him and I start typing a message
from my dad's account because I figured
that's how he's gonna open it cuz he's
like oh sure who's writing to me right
now I hit Send and then I'm just waiting
maybe he'll reply pretty quickly I'll
just leave the window open
I'm waiting have you ever found someone
else's email or Facebook open and your
computer's anyone what do you do do you
just like close it I mean at this point
I'm like maybe you should clean up those
Facebook messages you know you never
know
it'll just like get super full over the
next years and they'll just close his
email so I started cleaning them up
delete all those spammy messages and
then his last messages just rise to the
top I'm like oh there it is that's the
very last message he responded to
February 14 2014
this is like eight days before he was
admitted to the hospital to never return
home so I'm like wow look at my dad he
was still going at it it was a business
message I didn't realize what he had
been through those days because I live
almost 3,000 miles away from home I grew
up in Tijuana Mexico so that's really
far I didn't get to experience the last
days with him or my family get an idea
of what it was like what was he doing
during the day while he was like sick
and not feeling well what are you still
working which is amazing very inspiring
like what was he writing
open the email this email was to a
business acquaintance but my dad was
super friendly he would call him like a
very dear friend I knew who the guy was
I was like he spent two lines talking
about this like business deal or
something and then he changed the topic
abruptly and he wrote topic my health
I'm in this fight the good news is I
have great care from my wife my son my
sister and a nurse friend could can who
can occasionally tend to me when I'm not
feeling well I started crying it was
like holy like he was expressing
something in such few words and I don't
think he ever really shared that with us
I don't think he really told us how he
felt about the care he was receiving or
how grateful he was about it or how
positive he was about things even just
eight days before he was readmitted to
the hospital he passed away like 12 days
after that message he probably didn't
expect his life to end so soon and none
of us do really so it really shook me I
was like I think I missed a huge chunk
of what happened to him and my family by
being so far away so I kept going I kept
reading the messages I figured this is
the best way I have to understand what
happened so I keep scrolling and I find
more business messages messages from
family members like sending him articles
about the left latest miraculous cancer
cures and emails with to me and my
sister who don't live close to home I
couldn't stop it was just like this
window into his heart what he was
feeling the deepest messages were the
ones who were his friends of faith
people that were really supporting him
with faith in these hard moments and
they were the toughest because he would
share how scared he was and he said he
was scared of being alone and I felt so
guilty like I'm so far away he feels
alone like what's going on right but
then I read a message that really
inspired me it was a message to my
sister and he he wrote something that
just completely changed the course of my
life he wrote to her in a really short
email you build the road by moving along
never give up four months after that I
moved from New York City to San
Francisco left my comfortable job and
joined other three Italian co-founders
figured out the Mexican and three tally
ins to start a sleep technology company
no one thought we would be here no one
thought that what we were doing was a
viable business that we could survive
that we could get anywhere that no one
would fund this people foreigners with
accents like who are you and here we are
building the road as we move along and
not giving up and that's what I hope
that all of you get out of this is
something in your life will inspire you
one day to do whatever you want to do
maybe it's start a company maybe it's
write a book maybe is run for a class
president or like we're gonna nonprofit
or switch from teaching to like being a
media producer you never know just stay
close to the people that inspired you
the most and really watch out for their
accuse in their words and care for your
words because they can be in cyberspace
forever and you never know who they're
going to inspire thank you
[Applause]